～波の音～
～不気味な音～
バンッ
は）なぜ貴様がココにいるのか分からんのかぁー！
ト）知らんわ！うるせえ！
は）米を納めてないからじゃあー！（怒）
ト）ああ、うん…
は）貴様、ワシの村の掟を忘れたとでも言うのか？
は）ワシの村では、お前のような水呑み百姓は
は）毎月の終わりに年貢米を納めなければならないという義務がある
は）それなのに貴様はー！
は）なぜ今月の納め物がドーナツとスコーンなんじゃあ！
は）ナメとんのかぁ！貴様はー！
ト）違えい！違えい！
ト）ワシゃあ毎日頑張ってのぉー！
ト）お米作ろう、作ろうって頑張ったわい！
ト）お前のような悪代官様に、オラのような百姓もんの気持ちなど分かるかい！
ト）イモ焼酎飲みてぇ、イモ焼ちｘｙ…痛あーー！！！
は）百姓ごときがこのワシに口答えするとは百年早いわ
は）このアゴの魔物め、年貢米を出さぬと言うならば…
は）ココで成敗するでござるーーー！
ト）ええー、許してチョンマゲ、許してチョンマゲー
は）黙れ百姓め、貴様にもはや明日はない
は）See you next time…
さとちん）待たれよ！！
は）…誰だ？
さ）悪代官と言えど、人の殺生は見過ごせぬゆえに参った
さ）今、助けに参ったぞ！
さ）スグ助けに…明智光秀ぇー！！
さ）気持ちよいこと…いと限りなし
は）次は貴様だ、アゴ
ト）や、止めてよぉー、止めてよぉー
は）良いではないか、良いではないかぁー！
ト）ハンムラビ法典、ハンムラビ法典
は）ちこう寄れ、ちこう寄れぇー！
ト）や、や、や、止めろ、や、止めてくれ
ト）うわー！痛てっ！
ト）痛てぇよ、お前さマジでｗｗｗ
ト）お前さ…痛てぇよお前さっきからよ、おいコノヤロウｗｗ